PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
YOU ARE BASICALLY PRESENTING
YOURSELF LIKE A MORON.
FED UP WITH LISA'S
CRITICISM, CORYN FOUGHT BACK.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
ALCOHOLIC BITCH?
AND THE DRAMA CONTINUED
AT A COMMERCIAL SHOOT
WHEN THE MODELS
HAD TO REVEAL A SECRET.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK.
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT LIGHT.
NIK THOUGHT
THAT JAYLA STOLE HER SECRET.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT LIGHT.
WHICH THREW NIK
OFF HER GAME.
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG, YOU MIGHT...
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S IT.
AND SPARKED A FEUD.
IT'S OKAY.
'CAUSE KARMA'S A BITCH.
WHAT A STUPID LITTLE PERSON.
SHE IS.
I AM THIS CLOSE TO HATING HER.
BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS CORYN WHO WAS SENT HOME
WHEN SHE COULDN'T SHAKE
HER AIR OF GLOOMINESS.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
BRE, DO ME A FAVOR.
GRAB MY FOOT AND PULL.
OKAY, AND NOW DO ME A FAVOR,
PUSH MY LEG TOWARDS ME.
LAST WEEK WE HAD TO FILM
A COMMERCIAL FOR A SECRET
AND TALK ABOUT
ABOUT OUR PERSONAL SECRETS
AND JAYLA USED MY SECRET.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I AM AFRAID OF THE DARK
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT LIGHT.
I'M DEFINITELY UPSET
THAT JAYLA IS USING MY SECRET.
WHEN YOU FEEL CONFIDENT
AND STRONG,
YOU MIGHT REVEAL
SOMETHING ABOUT YOURSELF
THAT ORDINARILY YOU WOULD NOT.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I SLEEP WITH A NIGHT LIGHT.
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT I WAS THE ONE
WHO SLEEPS WITH A NIGHT LIGHT.
SO IT KIND OF SEEMS
LIKE BACKSTABBING.
IT CRACKED, IT CRACKED.
OKAY, DO THE OTHER ONE.
SHE'S ANGRY WITH ME
AND TREATING ME POORLY.
THAT SHOWS ME RIGHT THERE,
THAT SHE'S NOT A MATURE ENOUGH
PERSON TO HANDLE THE SITUATION.
AND SHE IS NOT GONNA LAST LONG.
HELLO.
WE'RE DOING A PHOTO SHOOT.
YES.
AND I AM GOING TO BE
COACHING YOU GUYS.
YAY!
I AM SO EXCITED TO DO THIS
PHOTO SHOOT WITH TYRA.
SERIOUSLY,
I SIGNED UP TO WORK WITH TYRA.
I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE,
BUT I KNOW
I SIGNED UP TO WORK WITH TYRA.
SO WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
A VERY NATURAL PHOTO SHOOT
TODAY.
IT'S GONNA BE
IN BLACK AND WHITE
AND KIND OF EDGY
AND DARK AND MYSTERIOUS.
I DO THESE PHOTO SHOOTS
WITH MY FRIENDS ALL THE TIME
AND WE HAVE FUN.
AND THIS IS ALL WE USE.
I'M GONNA PUT IT
ON YOUR CHEEK BONES.
AND IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU
A GLISTENED,
HIGH CHEEK BONE LOOK.
THIS REMINDS ME OF A FIERCE
BLACK-AND-WHITE PHOTO SHOOT
I DID WITH PAOLO ROVERSI.
FEEL WEIRD?
KIND OF,
I NEVER PUT VASELINE ON MY FACE.
ALL RIGHT, CHRISTIAN.
AND JUST BE VERY ETHEREAL
AND NOT SO POSY.
NEVER HAD SOMEONE HOLD
YOUR HAIR, RIGHT, FOR A PHOTO?
LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL IS SEE DOING?"
OH! OH!
YOU GONNA NEED
SOME DISHWASHING DETERGENT
TO GET THIS OUT.
DON'T FORGET THE NECK.
SHOW THEM THE NECK.
THERE YOU GO,
DON'T FORGET THE NECK.
TURN BACK TO HIM LIKE, "WHAT?"
AND ONE CRAZY ONE.
LAST, "HEY!"
OKAY!
THERE YOU GO.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
LIKE, "WHAT IS THIS?"
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT ARE YOU NERVOUS ABOUT?
JUST, IT'S SO NERVE-RACKING.
BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
KINDA JUST PUSHES YOU BACK.
NIK, YOU WENT FROM THE TOP
TO THE BOTTOM
BECAUSE YOU TOOK A PICTURE,
AND YOU DIDN'T ROCK IT.
SO HOPEFULLY,
I CAN GET MY MIND TOGETHER
SO I CAN FOCUS MORE
AND DO BETTER
IN THIS COMPETITION.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
I DID A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE I WAS HOLDING LEAVES
KINDA LIKE PEEK AROUND THEM.
JUST KINDA WORK THAT.
LIKE, "I'M WILD WOMAN."
I'M FEELING THE TREE."
ALL RIGHT, MISS JAYLA,
WHEN YOU LOOK IN THE MIRROR,
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK
LIKE YOU HAD A FIGHT.
THE FILM WILL LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I TRUST YOU.
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA, JUST LIKE,
"I'M A BABY AND I'M A VIRGIN."
CHRISTIAN,
IF YOU CAN COME RIGHT HERE.
BEAUTIFUL.
DO ONE WITH YOUR HAND,
LIKE A LITTLE SOFTER.
LOOK AT ME.
HOW IT'S LIKE, MAKING IT HEAVY.
RELAX YOUR PINKY.
JUST REALLY DRAMATIC-LIKE FACE.
CHIN UP A LITTLE.
NOW HOLD BOTH PIECES OF HAIR.
LIKE, LOOK, LOOK AT ME.
LIKE, "I'M JUST SO INNOCENT."
LOOK AT ME LIKE THIS, LIKE...
IT'S A LOT EASIER FOR ME
KNOWING THAT TYRA BANKS
IS RIGHT THERE.
BECAUSE SHE GIVES OFF
THIS ENERGY.
AND PULL YOUR NECK UP HIGH.
ETHEREAL ANGEL.
SWEET, SWEET.
PUT YOUR ARMS DOWN AND RELAX.
GET A LITTLE MORE,
"I'M INNOCENT. I'M JUST A BABY."
LIKE TILT YOUR HEAD BACK.
I KNOW THAT MY FACE
AND LIKE
MY LOOK IS VERY HIGH FASHION.
GIVE THAT BABY FACE,
LIKE, "HUH?"
BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO JUST PLAYING FEMININE,
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
HARDER FOR ME.
SO, KYLE,
I WANT YOU TO THINK GYPSY.
LIKE,
"I'M GONNA CAST YOUR FORTUNE."
STICK YOUR NECK OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
BREASTS BACK AND LOOK STRAIGHT
INTO THE CAMERA LIKE...
I DEFINITELY FEEL
LIKE I AM CUT OUT FOR THIS.
I THINK
THAT I COULD BE COACHED
AND TRAINED TO BE THE BEST.
GO LIKE THIS TO HIM.
THERE YOU GO! ALL RIGHT.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHRISTIAN,
SOMETIMES A PHOTO SHOOT
IS SHORT AND SWEET AND CUTE.
IT DON'T TAKE THE HOOPLA.
TYRA MAIL.
WAIT, DON'T READ IT YET.
WE'RE NOT DOWN THE STAIRS.
DON'T WORRY,
I'LL WAIT FOR YOU GUYS.
AH!
"YOU ARE GOING
TO PARIS TOMORROW!"
THAT IS NOT WHAT IT SAYS!
OKAY, GUYS, "ARE YOU
A DIAMOND IN THE ROUGH?"
THAT WASN'T FUNNY.
YOU LOVE IT.
AH!
EVERYONE IS GOING CRAZY HERE.
ME AND KIM ALWAYS JOKE THAT
WE'RE THE ONLY SANE ONES LEFT.
KYLE'S DOING REALLY WELL.
SHE'S GOT TWO OF THE CHALLENGES.
SHE JUST WON,
AND SHE'S DOING A GOOD JOB.
WHAT IF LIKE YOU GET LIKE
A MODELING CONTRACT
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"YOU HAVE TO MOVE TO NEW YORK."
I WOULD.
KYLE AND I JUST LIKE
I DON'T KNOW, WE JUST CLICK.
WE HAVE A GREAT TIME.
AND LIKE I FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH HER.
AND SHE'S PROBABLY
MY BEST FRIEND IN THE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ABOUT CHAD?
MY BOYFRIEND AND I
ARE FROM DIFFERENT CITIES.
AND WHEN WE CHOSE LIKE
WHICH COLLEGES WE WERE
GONNA GO TO,
THAT WAS HARD.
I'VE ALWAYS FOLLOWED HIM.
YOU KNOW,
NO MATTER WHAT HE WAS DOING.
IT'S LIKE, I KIND OF LIKE
PLANNED MY LIFE AROUND HIS
WHICH KIND OF SUCKS.
THAT IS NOT OKAY LIKE--
TO DO WHAT?
TO LIKE PLAN YOUR LIFE
AT ALL REGARDING SOMEONE ELSE.
LIKE EVERYONE I KNOW
BACK FROM LIKE HOME,
THEY'RE ALL LIKE,
"NO, YOU DO THINGS
FOR YOURSELF."
YEAH.
I THINK TO WIN,
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
YOU HAVE TO BE A SMART PERSON.
AND YOU CAN'T JUST GO OFF--
FEED OFF OF
WHAT OTHER PEOPLE SAY.
KYLE-- SHE DOES NOT SEEM
LIKE THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT'S VERY INTELLIGENT.
HI!
DOWN HERE, GALS.
TYRA MAIL SAYS,
"ARE YOU
A DIAMOND IN THE ROUGH?"
AND I'M TOTALLY CLUELESS
AS TO WHAT WE MIGHT BE DOING.
HI, GIRLS,
WELCOME TO CAMP TECHNIQUE.
SO WHAT YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING
IS A SERIES OF OBSTACLES.
BECAUSE TO BE A TOP MODEL
YOU HAVE TO BE TOUGHER
THAN YOUR COMPETITION.
AND TO BE ABLE TO TOUGH OUT
ANY SITUATION
THAT YOU ARE PUT INTO, OKAY?
ALL RIGHT, IS EVERYONE PREPARED?
SHE'S VERY PREPARED.
YOU'RE GONNA GET CHANGED.
AND I WILL SEE YOU
WHEN YOU COME BACK.
I DO WORK OUT EVERY DAY.
BUT I AM NOT PREPARED
AND PHYSICALLY FIT
FOR A BOOT CAMP.
LISA'S GONNA GO FIRST.
WHERE IS MY ARMY GREASE?
HERE YOU GO.
LISA IS IN HEAVEN.
SHE IS TOUGH.
YOU CAN GO LIKE THIS.
GO.
GO, LISA!
CLIMB THE HIGH WALL.
GO LISA.
COME ON, LISA!
DRAG IT!
ARMY FRONT CRAWL.
ALL THE WAY DOWN!
WAY TO GET DIRTY, GIRL!
I LOVE BEING DIRTY,
SO THIS, ACTUALLY,
IS NOTHING TO ME.
(groan)
NICE AND DIRTY, THERE YOU GO.
THE OBJECTIVE OF TODAY
WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GOT A GOOD WORKOUT.
BUT THE REAL OBJECTIVE
WAS TO MAKE SURE
THEY GOT DIRTY.
BECAUSE THIS IS PREPARATION
FOR THE REAL CHALLENGE TO COME.
OH!
NASTY.
THERE YOU GO!
I DEFINITELY THINK THAT
I NEED TO START WORKING OUT.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I AM GETTING OLDER.
AND I'M GONNA GET FATTER.
CAN'T TOUCH THAT NET.
BUT I REALLY DON'T THINK
THIS WAS THE WAY
TO GO ABOUT IT.
COME ON NOW!
KEEP YOUR HEAD DOWN.
BRE, GO.
MY BRA IS RUINED.
KIM, GO.
YEAH, KIM.
OKAY, KYLE, GO!
KEEP YOUR BUTT DOWN.
AND ON YOUR BACK.
JUST KEEP GOING.
I CAN FEEL IT GOING DOWN
MY PANTS.
AND I CAN FEEL IT IN MY EARS.
YOU CAN DO IT, KYLE! COME ON!
AND I CAN FEEL MY HAIR.
OH, IT'S JUST--
IT'S A GROSS FEELING.
EW, IT'S IN MY EAR.
KYLE, ONE COULD SAY
THAT SHE WASN'T AS INTO IT
AS EVERYBODY ELSE WAS.
GOOD LUCK, NICOLE.
ALL RIGHT, A HEART FOR YOU.
GO, NICOLE!
THERE YOU GO!
CRANK IT UP, NICOLE.
COME ON, PUSH THROUGH IT.
PUSH THROUGH IT.
COME ON!
AH.
LET'S GO, NICOLE.
NICOLE, SHE DID NOT HAVE FUN.
JUST THE COMPLAINTS IN GENERAL,
A LOT OF LIKE, "OH, MY GODS."
I'M GONNA BARF.
THAT WAS SO NASTY.
NIK, GO.
YOU ARE DOING GREAT.
GO, GO, GO.
WHOO!
GO, GO, GO, GO.
I THINK NIK HANDLED
THE SITUATION PRETTY WELL...
WITH HER PANTS PRACTICALLY
AT HER ANKLES.
DOWN, DOWN!
THERE YOU GO.
DON'T TOUCH THAT NET.
GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
LET'S GO. LET'S GO!
GIRL, YOU'RE ALMOST HOME FREE!
ACTUALLY, THAT WAS FUNNY.
AND IT WAS A FREEING FEELING.
I KNOW IT WAS TOUGH
WHEN YOU GOT DIRTY.
BUT YOU GUYS DID FANTASTIC.
NOW,
I DO HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU.
"YOU'RE DIRTY. YOU'RE GRIMY
YOU'RE STINKY. YOU'RE SMELLY.
SO TODAY YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FAKE THE FUNK. TYRA."
WHAT THE HELL DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WE DON'T KNOW.
DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
LIKE THIS.
I DON'T ENJOY BEING COVERED
IN DIRT AND GRIME.
HOWEVER, IF IT'S GONNA GET ME
CLOSER TO THE TOP,
I GUESS IT'S ALL WORTH IT.
OH, THIS IS SO SAD.
I FELT LIKE
I WAS GONNA THROW UP.
I'M NOT LIKE,
I WASN'T EVEN LIKE
EXAGGERATING.
THIS IS NUTS.
PEOPLE CAN'T SIT AROUND
AND BE DIRTY ALL DAY.
I FEEL LIKE A CAGED RAT.
OH, GROSS.
BEING COVERED
IN ALL THAT STUFF--
IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
MY HAIR WAS--
IT LOOKED LIKE A COW PIE.
WHAT DID THE TYRA MAIL SAY?
FAKE THE FUNK.
YEAH, FAKE THE FUNK.
SO WE HAVE TO FAKE
THE NASTY SMELL.
OH, BELIEVE ME,
I DON'T HAVE TO FAKE THE FUNK.
YOU CAN'T MOVE
BECAUSE YOU'RE WET AND SLIMY.
AND WE PULL UP TO THIS LOFT
IN L.A.
WE'RE CLUELESS
ON WHAT'S GOING ON.
HI.
I AM BRANDON HOLLEY.
I'M FROM "ELLE GIRL."
I'M THE EDITOR.
THIS IS MARIE, OUR ART DIRECTOR,
AND GLORIA, OUR FASHION EDITOR.
SO HOW DO YOU FEEL RIGHT NOW?
YOU'RE ON A GO-SEE.
THE WINNER OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WILL ALSO BE ON THE COVER
OF "ELLE GIRL."
AND EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE COVERED IN MUD,
YOU HAVE TO LET
YOUR NATURAL PERSONALITY
SHINE THROUGH.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
OR IS THE MUD MAKING YOU--
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
JUST GOTTA GO IN AND JUST
SHOW MY PERSONALITY.
'CAUSE YOU'RE DEFINITELY
NOT GONNA GO
ON THESE LOOKS RIGHT NOW.
WHAT CAN MY READER
SEE IN YOU THAT'S DIFFERENT?
IN MY PICTURES
I LIKE TO SHOW LIKE
A LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
SOMETHING LIKE,
"YEAH, YOU WANT TO READ THIS,
UH-HUH."
WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU COULD BRING
TO AN "ELLE GIRL" COVER?
LOOKING AT ALL THESE COVERS,
THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME
FACIAL EXPRESSION, SAME SMILE.
MY SMILE WOULD BE BIG.
BE LIKE THIS...
ONE OF MY MOTTOS IS
"DARE TO BE DIFFERENT."
TELL US
HOW YOU DARE TO BE DIFFERENT?
I KINDA LIKE TO HAVE FUN,
BUT I HAVE FUN IN WEIRD WAYS.
LIKE WHAT?
LIKE PLAYING IN THE MUD
IS ACTUALLY FUN.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST ONE OF THOSE TYPES
OF PEOPLE WHO LIKES
TO GET INTO THINGS
AND MESS THINGS UP.
WHAT MAKES YOU DIFFERENT?
MY TASTE IN MUSIC IS
IS DEFINITELY DIFFERENT
THAN EVERYONE ELSE'S.
WHICH IT IS?
I LISTEN TO LIKE
ELECTROCLASH, PSYCHOBILLY,
HARDCORE.
YOU KNOW WHAT,
THAT'S VERY "ELLE GIRL."
AFTER ROLLING THE MUD ALL DAY,
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
WELL, AT FIRST--
I FEEL OKAY NOW.
BUT THE MUD
WAS A LITTLE SMELLY.
I'M SURPRISED THAT "ELLE GIRL"
WANTED TO TALK
TO OUR SMELLY BUTTS.
WHO WOULD WANNA TALK
TO SOMEONE WHO HAS
ROLLED AROUND IN POOP?
SO WHEN WE WERE ROLLING
THROUGH THE MUD, I WAS LIKE,
"UGH"
I ALMOST PUKED.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL OUR READERS
ABOUT YOURSELF?
WELL, I'M FROM
A REALLY SMALL TOWN.
YOU KNOW,
I WORK AT THE LOCAL DAIRY QUEEN.
I'M JUST, YOU KNOW,
THE LOCAL SMALL-TOWN GIRL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PASSION?
I LOVE JEWELRY.
JEWELRY IS MY MAIN THING.
LIKE I HAVE SO MANY EARRINGS.
EARRINGS ARE MY PASSION.
I WAS MYSELF.
I WAS JUST NATURAL.
I WASN'T NERVOUS AT ALL.
BUT, UM, HOPEFULLY,
IT'S MY THIRD WIN.
MY STYLE IS LIKE
THE WAY THAT I EXPRESS MYSELF.
AND LIKE
MY SEXUALITY AND EVERYTHING,
IT'S LIKE
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT MY OUTWARD APPEARANCE.
WHAT IF WE PUT YOU
IN A SUPER FRILLY
GIRLIE-GIRL DRESS?
NO, I MEAN,
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
ONE OF THE MAIN ASPECTS OF
OF BEING A MODEL
IS BEING REALLY VERSATILE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE
SOME POLAROID'S OF YOU.
THE DIRT'S A GREAT ACCESSORY.
MY PUNK FACE.
MORE ENERGY.
HI.
THIS HAS BEEN GREAT FOR US.
BECAUSE EACH OF YOU WAS ABLE TO
SHOW US A BIT ABOUT YOURSELF.
SO THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS GOING TO RECEIVE SOMETHING
REALLY AWESOME--
A ONE-ON-ONE LESSON
FROM A FASHION INDUSTRY EXPERT
ON HOW TO BE A REAL MODEL.
AND ONLY ONE OF YOU WILL WIN.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
GO DOWN AND TELL YOU EACH
WHAT WE THOUGHT OF YOU.
LISA, YOU HAD GREAT ENERGY
FROM THE SECOND YOU WALKED
IN THE ROOM.
JAYLA, YOU SEEMED REALLY SHY
AND LIKE YOU WERE
UNDER A LOT OF STRESS
AND ABOUT TO CRACK.
I'M COVERED IN MUD,
AND I'M GOING ON A GO-SEE.
YOU CAN'T LET PEOPLE KNOW
WHEN YOU FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
BRE, I THINK
YOU SHOWED A LOT OF CONFIDENCE,
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT DIDN'T ALWAYS COME
ACROSS IN THE POLAROIDS.
NIK, MY ONE CRITIQUE WOULD BE
THAT YOU NEED
A LITTLE MORE ENERGY.
NICOLE, YOU JUST HAVE
THIS LIKE
AMERICA'S SWEETHEART THING
GOING ON.
AND THAT'S DEFINITELY
A TYPE OF LOOK
THAT PEOPLE ARE, YOU KNOW,
INTERESTED IN.
KIM, YOU'RE TOUGH,
AND YOU'VE GOT YOUR OWN THING.
AND I LOVE IT.
BUT YOU'VE GOTTA BE ABLE
TO CHANGE IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
KYLE, I LOVE THAT YOU WORKED
AT DAIRY QUEEN.
THAT'S SO AWESOME.
YEAH.
YOU'RE REALLY SUPER STRIKING.
YOU'VE GOT GREAT BONE STRUCTURE.
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
MAYBE YOU NEED TO WORK ON
A RANGE OF EXPRESSIONS.
NOW THAT WE'VE MET
ALL OF YOU,
WE'VE COME TO A DECISION.
SO THE ONE THAT WE PICKED
UM, WAS LISA.
YOU'RE THE WINNER
OF THE CHALLENGE.
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
IS A REALLY COOL
FASHION CRASH COURSE.
THEY TOLD ME THEY THOUGHT
THAT I WAS FANTASTIC.
HOWEVER, AS USUAL,
MY POSING WASN'T PERFECT
IN THE PICTURES,
SO THEY CHOSE LISA.
I PERSONALLY THINK
SHE'S THE LEAST PRETTY
OF EVERYONE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO YOU GUYS WANT HUGS?
NO, THANK YOU.
NO,
I CALLED THE SHOWER SECOND!
YOU CAN TAKE THAT ONE.
PLEASE HURRY UP
WITH THE SHOWERS, YOU GUYS.
OVERALL,
THE DAY IS KIND OF DEPRESSING.
I'M JUST REALLY UPSET
WITH MYSELF THAT I DIDN'T DO
AS WELL AS I'D PLANNED.
I JUST WON THE CHALLENGE
WHERE I GET TO LEARN A BUNCH OF
THINGS FROM A FASHION EXPERT.
AND I AM SO EXCITED.
HELLO.
HELLO, I'M TODD HALLMAN.
HELLO. LISA.
CELEBRITY STYLIST,
FASHION RUNWAY PRODUCER.
COME.
I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU AN EDGE.
SO WE'LL GET IN SOME CLOTHES.
WE'LL WALK.
WE'LL SEE
WHAT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH.
JAYLA,
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU DIDN'T
TAKE A SHOWER
AND YOU'RE SITTING ON THE BED,
I PUT A TOWEL DOWN.
GROSS.
THAT'S DISGUSTING, DUDE.
TAKE A SHOWER
BEFORE YOU SIT ON A BED.
KIM'S REALLY SARCASTIC
ABOUT THINGS.
UM, I DON'T THINK
THAT SHE FEELS
THAT SHE'S DOING TOO WELL.
OH, LIFE IS SO RICH
RIGHT NOW.
I AM USED TO BEING
LIKE ONE OF THE BEST.
AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
ONE OF THE BEST HERE.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO FIX THIS.
YOU NEED TO HAVE
A STRONGER CONVICTION.
WHEN YOU WALK OUT,
YOU NEED TO SELL IT.
LOOK UP. HEAD UP.
WHY IS YOUR HEAD DOWN?
WATCH YOUR HANDS.
SOLID POSITION AT THE END.
PRACTICE UNTIL YOU DROP.
GET OUT OF THIS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
ALL RIGHT.
LISA, I THINK, IS AMAZING.
SHE HAS PIERCING EYES.
SHE'LL BE ABLE TO PULL YOU IN.
ALSO, SPEND TIME WITH YOUR FACE.
BE KIND TO YOUR SKIN.
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
THAN A TIRED MODEL.
IF YOU FALL,
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
JUST BE CHARMING
AND LIKE, "I'M HUMAN, TOO."
GET UP AND HIT IT AGAIN.
THIS WIN WITH TODD
MAY GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF AN UPPER HAND,
WHICH IS FINE WITH ME.
GIVE ME A HUG.
HUG.
THANK YOU, MAN.
OH, WE HAVE TYRA MAIL.
LISA, JAYLA,
TYRA MAIL!
"VROOM, VROOM.
BE READY TOMORROW AT 8:15 A.M."
SOMETHING WITH CARS.
KYLE, COME OUTSIDE.
WOULD YOU COME AND SIT WITH ME?
HEY, KYLE, WHY DON'T YOU TRY
TO BE READY ON TIME TODAY?
THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA.
DUDE, ALL MY EYEBROWS
ARE GROWING BACK IN.
ALL I REALLY AM THINKING
ABOUT NOW IS JUST TRYING
TO DO BETTER.
'CAUSE I FEEL LIKE
EVERY WEEK FOR ME--
IT'S LIKE I'M HANGING ON
BY A STRING.
OW!
OH, DEAR!
THAT REALLY HURT.
I JUST HOPE
THAT I GET ANOTHER CHANCE
THIS WEEK.
SO I JUST WANNA LIKE
ROCK ONE COMPETITION,
ONE CHALLENGE,
ONE PHOTO SHOOT.
HAVE FUN WITH THAT.
YEAH, THANKS.
GOOD MORNING.
HI.
SO THIS WEEK
YOU GIRLS LEARNED ALL ABOUT
INNER CONFIDENCE, RIGHT?
IT'S NOT WHAT YOU WEAR,
IT'S HOW YOU WEAR IT.
AND THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR A TOP MODEL TO KNOW
HOW TO WEAR IT.
LOOK AT KIM, SHE'S LIKE,
"LORD JESUS,
WHAT IS THIS MAN
PUTTING ON ME TODAY?"
WE ARE GONNA RIDE THAT FINE LINE
OF SEXY VERSUS SLEAZY.
TYRA IS THE MASTER OF THIS.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO WORK IT.
WELL, WE ARE GONNA ACTUALLY DO
A SHOOT FOR FORD FUSION,
WHICH IS A SUPER HOT CAR.
AND IT IS ALL ABOUT BEING GROWN
AND SEXY.
AND THE FORD FUSION
GENERATES HEAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS MAKE YOU GUYS LIKE
THIS MODERN VERSION
OF A '40s PINUP GIRL.
AND THE EVENTUAL WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
WILL HAVE TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPH
MADE INTO A NATIONAL AD
FOR THE FORD FUSION.
ARE YOU GUYS FAMILIAR
WITH THE '40s PINUP GIRLS?
YEAH, VARGAS GIRLS.
VARGAS GIRLS, OH, WOW!
A GIRL WHO KNOWS
A REFERENCE FOR A CHANGE.
THIS IS LOVELY!
COOL, ALL RIGHT, LET'S START.
I'M REALLY GIRLIE.
SO I'M PRETTY PLEASED WITH THAT.
WHENEVER THERE'S LIKE
AN EXTREMELY FEMININE SHOOT,
OBVIOUSLY,
I'M A LITTLE BIT WORRIED.
I REALLY WANT TO DO A GOOD JOB
AND I HOPE THAT I DO.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT
THAT WE'RE DOING TODAY--
OLD PINUP GIRL
WITH THE NEW FORD FUSION CAR.
I MEAN, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I CAN DO, IT'S SOMETHING
I'M FAMILIAR WITH,
SO I THINK I'VE GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF AN EDGE AT IT.
SO I'LL HAVE TO HELP
YOU GIRLS GET
INTO THESE CORSETS,
BECAUSE THEY ARE GONNA BE TINY.
HOLD ON TIGHT.
LET ME KNOW WHEN
YOU CAN'T BREATHE,
AND THEN I'LL KEEP DOING IT
A TINY BIT MORE.
ALL RIGHT.
IT'S SO FUNNY TO SEE YOU
AS A GIRL-GIRL.
YOU'RE SO CUTE AND PRETTY.
FOR TODAY, ARCH THE BACK,
GIVE ME ALL CURVES AND SEXY.
NICE. BEAUTIFUL.
WORK IN THERE FOR A MINUTE.
THERE YOU GO.
IF YOU GOT IT, FLAUNT IT.
I LIKE THE LITTLE BUTT
AND THE LITTLE CHEEKS
HANGING OUT.
IT'S CUTE.
YOU WERE MUCH MORE AWARE
OF YOUR BODY TODAY AND FACE.
I DIDN'T GET THAT MANY
YOU KNOW, LIKE MUG-FACE SHOTS,
THESE... (grunts)
ARE YOU READY?
NICE, NICE.
JAYLA, I ALSO WANT TO SEE
THAT LITTLE BLING IN FRONT.
ARCH THE BACK A LITTLE MORE.
WORK WITH THAT.
KEEP PLAYING WITH IT.
IT'S WORKING.
NICE. BEAUTIFUL!
RIGHT IN THERE. THAT'S COOL.
NICOLE, YOU BETTER FIND
SOMETHING INSIDE OF YOU, GIRL.
IS SHE ALIVE?
SO, NICOLE,
I KNOW YOU CAN'T BREATHE
AND EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
I HAD TO WEAR SOMETHING
THAT WAS SUCTIONED
TO MY BODY, AND IT WAS
HARD FOR ME TO BREATHE.
BOOTY STICKING OUT... OOH!
I FELT LIKE
I WAS GONNA FAINT.
I'M GONNA LIKE
PASS OUT, SERIOUSLY.
WELL, IF YOU FEEL-- WAIT.
IF YOU FEEL WEAK,
JUST SAY, "I NEED A SECOND."
GIVE ME THE BIG SMILE
IN THERE.
SMILE, SMILE!
THOSE ARE CUTE, NICOLE!
GIVE US A BIG, LUSCIOUS,
WATERMELON BUTT.
TWIST THAT SUCKER
TO ME LIKE THAT.
BRING THE ASS UP A LITTLE.
YEAH, GIVE ME THE TEETH!
GIVE ME THE TEETH! YES! YES!
WELL, I'M NERVOUS, BUT I HAVE
SOME KIND OF NATURAL TALENT.
I WANT TO EXCEL.
HEY, KIM,
YOU GOTTA THINK PINUP-Y.
OOH. LET ME SEE.
UH-HUH.
GIVE ME A LITTLE--
OH, THAT'S GREAT.
HEY, KIM?
IN THE BEGINNING,
YOU LOOK REAL FEMININE,
AND I LOVE THE BODY SHAPES.
AND NOW IT'S STARTING
TO GET A LITTLE BUTCH.
(chuckles)
NO THINKING.
BRING IT ON. THERE YOU GO.
NICE. GIVE IT TO ME.
THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S A NICE ONE.
THAT'S GOOD.
SERIOUSLY, IT'S NOT BAD.
THIS IS TRULY THE MOST
FEMININE I'VE SEEN YOU LOOK.
I'M TRYING.
NO, IT LOOKS GOOD.
I MEAN, YOU LOOK FEMININE
AND SOFT AND SUPPLE.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
KIM IS NOT A GIRLIE GIRL,
AND TODAY WAS ALL ABOUT
BEING GIRLIE AND SEXY.
AND KIM GAVE US THAT.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED.
SHE KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S DOING ANYWAYS.
SHE'S JUST TRYING TO GET YOU
ALL BUTTERED UP, AND THEN
SHE'S GONNA GO UP THERE
AND GIVE YOU BAM!
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
YEAH, THAT'S GREAT.
GOOD, GOOD, NICE, NICE.
YEP, PERFECT.
DON'T FORGET YOUR LEGS.
THEY JUST LOOK LIKE THEY'RE
HANGING THERE LIKE A MUPPET.
SOMETIMES THE FEET TOGETHER
LOOKS VERY VARGAS LIKE THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YOU GOT SOME IN THERE.
YOU'RE STRUGGLED A BIT IN
THE BEGINNING THERE, MISS THING.
JUST TO KNOW
THAT THE LAST THING I HEAR
COMING OUT OF THE PHOTO SHOOT
IS THAT I STRUGGLED THROUGH
THE BEGINNING OF IT REALLY PUTS
ME INTO A BAD PLACE RIGHT NOW.
I NEED THE PHOTO SHOOT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
KYLE, LET'S DO IT.
YOU LOOK VERY, UM, ASHLEY JUDD.
ASHLEY JUDD. DO I?
YEAH.
BUT YOU'RE MUCH PRETTIER
THAN HER.
BEAUTIFUL.
DON'T LEAN BACK TOO FAR.
THAT'S LOOKING GOOD, KYLE.
WATCHING KYLE WAS
REALLY NERVE-RACKING
BECAUSE TO ME, THE SECOND
KYLE WALKED OUT THERE
SHE LOOKED GORGEOUS.
EVERYONE SAYS THAT KYLE IS
SO BEAUTIFUL, BUT I REALLY THINK
THAT KYLE LACKS A LOT OF DEPTH.
OOH, THAT LOOKS GOOD.
OOH, OOH, JUST ONE THING.
I REALLY THINK THAT SHE HAS
NEXT TO NO PERSONALITY.
THAT WAS HER LAST FRAME.
THANKS, KYLE.
FOR SOME REASON, IT WAS
LIKE HARD FOR ME TO MAKE
MAKE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS TODAY.
NO, IT'S SO GOOD.
THANKS.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS HOW
PAINFUL THIS CORSET IS.
IT PUSHES YOUR RIB CAGE
AND LIKE YOUR ORGANS IN.
IT'S LIKE EXCRUCIATING PAIN
WEARING THIS CORSET.
CAN WE LACE HER UP TIGHTER?
(groans)
YEAH, DON'T CRACK HER RIBS.
JUST-- THERE YOU GO.
JUST A LITTLE. THAT'S GREAT.
I'M TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
BREATHE COMFORTABLY
WITHOUT PASSING OUT.
OH, THAT'S GOOD.
NOW GIVE ME THE EYES.
YEAH, THERE'S THE EYES.
NOW WITH BRE, I DON'T THINK
SHE WAS 100% FOCUSED.
SHE'S TRYING, THOUGH.
WHATEVER WAS HOLDING HER BACK,
SHE WANTED TO TRY.
TYRA MAIL!
(all shouting)
WAIT, WHO WANTS TO READ IT
TODAY?
YOU ARE.
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY SIX WILL CONTINUE
ON THE HOPE OF BECOMING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
PRETTY MUCH ONE OF OUR ASSES
ARE LEAVING TOMORROW.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I HOPE IT'S NOT ME.
I DON'T WANT EVERYONE TO
JUST SIT AROUND AND LIKE
COMPLAIN ABOUT EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW, LIKE
LET'S GET UP AND DO SOMETHING.
SO WE'RE IN THE LIMO AND WE'RE
ON OUR WAY TO VENICE CANTINA.
♪♪♪
WE PUT MUSIC ON.
WE WERE DANCING AROUND.
WE ALL GOT TO JUST CHILL OUT.
IT WAS FUN.
I HOPE THAT THE JUDGES
GIVE ME CREDIT FOR IMPROVING
EVERY SINGLE TIME, 'CAUSE
RIGHT NOW I DO FEEL LIKE
I'M ON FIRE, AND I WANNA
KEEP IT THAT WAY.
WE'RE HAVING A GOOD TIME.
WELL, I'M NOT.
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE ALL WORKED
REALLY HARD TO BE AT THIS POINT.
I HAVEN'T HAD THE STRONGEST
PICTURES, SO I'M JUST ANXIOUS TO
SEE WHAT TYPE OF PICTURE
MIGHT COME OUT.
IF I LEAVE,
I LOVED EVERYONE HERE.
AND IF I DON'T LEAVE,
I'M GONNA MISS WHOEVER
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA
GO BYE-BYE.
BUT IT'S PROBABLY GONNA BE ME.
I'M UNDER THE MOST INTENSE
PRESSURE RIGHT NOW.
I HATE TO SAY IT, BUT MY HEART,
JUST BECAUSE I DID SO BAD.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING HOME.
HI, GIRLS.
HI.
Y'ALL LOOKING KINDA SEXIFIED
TODAY. WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU LOOK LOVELY,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR SIXTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND YOU KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES--
A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY,
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A COVER OF "ELLE GIRL"
MAGAZINE,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT WITH
COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE,
WE HAVE OUR JUDGES--
THE NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NIGEL BARKER,
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
OUR FABULOUS RUNWAY COACH.
AND HIS HAIR IS LOVELY TODAY.
HEY, GIRLS, WHAT'S GOING ON?
TWIGGY, LEGENDARY FASHION
ICON IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND RICHARD DEAN.
RICHARD DEAN IS
AN AMAZING FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT YOU ALL SHOT WITH
THIS WEEK.
SO THIS WEEK YOU GUYS LEARNED
ABOUT BEING SEXY VERSUS
BEING SLEAZY
AND HAVING CONFIDENCE
COME FROM WITHIN.
SO TODAY, I WANT YOU
TO VISUALLY EXPRESS
WHAT SEXY MEANS TO YOU.
SO IN A ROOM BACK THERE
THERE'S LOTS OF CLOTHES,
ACCESSORIES.
YOU'VE GOT THREE MINUTES
TO PUT TOGETHER YOUR LOOK.
ALL RIGHTY, GO!
SEXY, SEXY, SEXY, SEXY!
♪♪♪
HI.
SO WHAT MADE YOU DECIDE ON
THIS OUTFIT?
I WAS THINKING ABOUT A STORY.
IF YOU DRESS UP AND YOU'RE
STRUTTING THE STRUT
AND SOMEONE COMES UP TO YOU
AND THEY WANNA TALK TO YOU
OR THEY JUST TELL YOU
HOW BEAUTIFUL YOU ARE,
THIS PERSON JUST WANTS TO TALK
TO ME BECAUSE I LOOK HOT
RIGHT NOW.
AND ACTUALLY I THINK
A LITTLE WHITE SINGLET
AND JEANS IS VERY SEXY.
I THINK YOU LOOK GREAT,
ACTUALLY.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
HEY.
HI, NICOLE.
SO TELL US ABOUT YOUR OUTFIT.
IT'S JUST KIND OF
CUTE AND SEXY.
(imitates buzzer)
NOT WORKING FOR YOU?
ME EITHER.
EVEN HOW YOU'RE STANDING.
IT'S LIKE SLEW FOOT AND OPEN
AND LIKE A PENGUIN.
THE WAY YOU'RE STANDING
IS COMPLETELY DESTROYING
MY THOUGHTS AND MY VISION.
BUT, NICOLE, I KINDA FEEL
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
KINDA HIPPY CHIC, HIPPY SEXY.
YEAH.
MISS BRE, SO TELL US
ABOUT YOUR OUTFIT.
IF MY BOYFRIEND COMES HOME,
HE'D RATHER ME BE NATURAL
AND BE MYSELF INSTEAD OF ME
BEING DRESSED AND DOLLED UP
AND BEAUTIFIED.
I WOULD HAVE HAD
YOUR HAIR DOWN.
WHY DON'T YOU PULL IT DOWN
AND MESS IT UP?
YEAH.
OR A BIT LIKE THIS.
THERE YOU GO.
DO IT LIKE THIS.
OH, YEAH, THAT'S REAL SEXY.
OH, YEAH, THAT'S BETTER.
OH, THERE. OH, WOW. YEAH.
HI.
HOUSEWIFE'S CHOICE.
I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT T-SHIRT'S THE RIGHT COLOR
OR-- I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE NOT
THINKING.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE DOING IT
ON PURPOSE, BUT YOU'VE GOT
TO BE SMART, TOO.
THE OUTFIT DOESN'T SUIT
YOUR BODY.
YOU'RE NOT SELLING IT.
IF YOU WALKED OUT OF HERE
AND YOU HAD YOUR HAND LIKE
HOOKED ON THAT SKIRT,
WE MIGHT BE LIKE, "WHOA!"
CAN YOU DO A SPIN?
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, KYLE.
OKAY.
FINALLY SOMEBODY CAME IN
WITH SOMETHIN'.
OKAY, OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
I THINK YOU LOOK FABULOUS.
I LOVE IT.
YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE HAVING FUN.
ALL THESE OTHER GIRLS ARE
TAKING THIS SO SERIOUSLY,
AND "I'M GONNA BE SAFE."
SO FAR YOU'VE BLOWN THE GIRLS
AWAY THAT HAVE COME BEFORE YOU.
AWESOME. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NIK,
SO EXPLAIN YOUR OUTFIT.
I PICKED A SIMPLE BLACK
DRESS 'CAUSE I THINK ALL WOMEN
LOOK GREAT IN BLACK DRESSES.
I'VE PULLED MY HAIR BACK
AND PUT IT IN A BUN.
I THINK YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I JUST WOULD HAVE LOVED TO SEE
A RED LIP.
JUST IT DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
YOU'VE GOTTA BRING
THE SEX APPEAL.
IT'S YOU THAT'S SEXY.
IT'S NOT YOUR OUTFIT.
IT'S HOW YOU SELL IT,
AND I THINK THAT'S THE MAGIC.
OKAY, NOW YOU'RE STARTING
TO LOOK A LITTLE SEXY
AND CUTE.
YOU HAD THE OUTFIT.
IT WAS JUST--
YOU WEREN'T SELLING IT.
HI, KIM, SO TELL US
ABOUT YOUR OUTFIT.
I DON'T KNOW, I THINK
SOMETIMES JUST LIKE A PREPPY,
SORT OF OUT FOR TENNIS,
KIND OF SWEATY.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN THE SEXY THING AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS
YOU'RE GIVING US FANTASY.
YEAH, EXACTLY--
THAT'S A WHOLE 'NOTHER THING.
YOURFANTASY.
OH, YEAH.
THE TENNIS SHOES
AND THE MINISKIRT REALLY WORK.
CAN YOU GIVE US A TWIRL?
(laughs) SURE.
OOH.
WHOO.
SO YOU GUYS HAD A COUPLE OF
PHOTO SHOOTS.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT WITH MOI
AND WAS TRYING TO FIND QUIET,
CONFIDENT SEXY WITHOUT BEING
OVERBOARD.
LISA, COME FORWARD.
SO YOU HAD A HEADSHOT
THAT I COACHED YOU ON.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
LOVE IT. FABULOUS.
THAT'S A GREAT SHOT.
I LOVE IT.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT LITTLE
5-MINUTE PHOTO SHOOT COULD
TURN OUT SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
DID YOU?
IT MAKES ME WANNA KNOW MORE.
IT MAKES ME WANNA
KEEP LOOKING.
I THINK IT'S VERY GOOD.
YOU ALSO HAD TO BE
VARGAS GIRLS THIS WEEK,
KIND OF PUSHING THE SEXY
ALMOST RIGHT BEFORE IT TURNED
INTO SLEAZY.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
LISA, I THINK WITH BOTH
OF THESE PHOTOGRAPHS,
YOU'VE PROVED TO US THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY REALLY LEARNING
TO MODEL.
YOU'VE SHOWN TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT LOOKS.
I ACTUALLY HAVE THOUGHT YOU
COULD BE AN ACTRESS, AND YOU
HAVE TO BE AN ACTRESS
TO BE A GOOD MODEL,
AND THESE SHOTS PROVE IT.
NEXT IS BRE,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LOVE IT. YOU LOOK AS THOUGH
YOU'RE PISSED AS HELL THAT
SOMEONE'S PULLING YOUR HAIR.
I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN
A PHOTOGRAPH YET THAT'S
DONE YOU JUSTICE, AND I THINK
THIS ONE, FOR ME, DOES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS PICTURE?
I'M NOT ON THE SAME LEVEL
AS A LOT OF GIRLS,
SO I DIDN'T EXPECT TO DO
BETTER THAN THE NEXT GIRL.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
YOU'RE NOT ON THE SAME LEVEL?
WHEN THE CAMERAS WERE THERE,
I WOULD KINDA FREEZE UP.
WHAT WERE YOU AFRAID OF?
BEING IMPERFECT.
I WAS AFRAID OF WHAT PEOPLE
WOULD THINK WHEN THEY SAW
THE PICTURES--
'CAUSE I MEAN, I'M PERFECT.
TYRA'S NOT PERFECT,
BUT I MEAN, I'M PERFECT, SO...
I THINK YOU REALLY NEED TO
LISTEN TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
RIGHT NOW.
THIS COULD BE YOUR EPIPHANY.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU ALSO HAD
A PINUP PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
LOOKS LIKE SHE'S
GONNA CLIMB OVER A FENCE.
I LOVE THE LEG.
I THINK IT'S VERY SEXY.
YOU WERE THINKING A LITTLE
TOO MUCH ON THE PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU WERE NERVOUS
AND STRESSED OUT AND THINKING.
ALL RIGHT, BRE, THANKS.
JAYLA, SO YOU HAD A NATURAL
INNER BEAUTY SEXY SHOT WITH ME,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT PINKIE.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
I SAID, "RELAX THAT PINKIE."
IT NEVER WANTS TO GO DOWN.
IT'S GOT A LIFE OF ITS OWN.
SO YOU ALSO HAD A PHOTO WHERE
YOU WERE A 1940s PINUP,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE POSE IS RIGHT.
IT JUST NEEDED A SLIGHT...
WELL, MAYBE IN THE FACE,
YOU KNOW, A LITTLE MORE...
YOU'RE LUCKY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT MUCH.
IT'S LIKE THOSE ACTORS
THAT JUST KINDA HAVE IT,
AND THEY JUST DO A LITTLE,
LIKE ROBERT De NIRO.
YOU DON'T SEE HIM IN A SCENE
GOING, "OH, I LOVE YOU!"
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA, THANKS.
UP NEXT IS NIK.
AS SHE WALKS UP SEXY,
PUTS HER HANDS ON HER HIPS,
AND STRIKES A POSE.
I WANTED NIGEL TO BELIEVE
THAT I LOOK SEXY IN THE DRESS,
AND I FEEL LIKE I'M SEXY.
I'M A BELIEVER.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
RAW, SEXY.
THEY'RE VERY HAUNTING.
YOU WERE DESIGNED FOR THIS
KIND OF PHOTOGRAPHY.
THE SORT OF RESERVEDNESS
THAT YOU HAVE.
WEEK BY WEEK, YOU HAVE
ACTUALLY CHANGED YOUR LOOK UP,
AND IT'S GOOD FOR US TO SEE
LOTS OF DIFFERENT SIDES TO YOU.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU ALSO HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT WHERE
YOU HAD TO BE A PINUP.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOUR BODY TENDS TO
PHOTOGRAPH SLIGHTLY ATHLETIC
AND YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF BODY FAT, WHICH IS
A GOOD THING FOR A MODEL.
THEY DON'T REALLY WANT YOU
TO HAVE A LOT OF BODY FAT,
BUT IN DOING THIS, YOU NEED
A LITTLE EXTRA, YOU KNOW,
TO DO THE PINUP-Y THINGS.
SO THAT WAS YOUR STRUGGLE,
SO YOU NEEDED TO EXAGGERATE
LIKE THEY'RE SAYING.
PUSH IT OUT AND PUSH IT BACK.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
THOSE CURVES,
SO YOU HAVE TO CREATE THEM.
TOOT THE BOOTY.
IF YOU'D DID A TOOT THE BOOTY,
YOU WOULD HAVE HAD
SOME MORE LUSCIOUSNESS IN
THE PHOTO.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
NEXT IS NICOLE.
SO YOU HAD TO DO A NATURAL
PHOTO SHOOT WITH ME,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THESE PHOTOGRAPHS ARE
ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL.
HOW WERE YOU FEELING
AT THIS SHOOT?
I DON'T KNOW.
I LIKE THE PICTURE A LOT.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE
YOU GIVE IT LITTLE
SUBTLE VARIATIONS.
SO EVEN THOUGH I'M SAYING,
"I'M ANGELIC, I'M A VIRGIN,"
IT'S...
SO YOU'RE NOT ONE STEP UP
FROM BLAH.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE
DEFINITELY PICKED IT UP
SINCE THEN. I DEFINITELY AM
WAY OVER ONE STEP OF BLAH.
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR PRESENCE
IS STILL ALMOST LACKADAISICAL.
THERE'S ONE THING
THAT MY MOTHER DOESN'T LIKE--
WHEN SHE'S TELLING SOMEBODY
SOMETHING, AND THEY GO,
"OKAY. OKAY. OKAY."
IT'S DEFENSIVE,
AND YOU DO IT EVERY SINGLE WEEK,
AND IT'S NOT LIKEABLE,
AND YOU'RE A SWEET GIRL.
OKAY. I'LL WORK ON THAT.
MAYBE IT'S GOOD
THAT IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT.
SORRY. I REALLY DON'T REALIZE
THAT I'M DOING IT.
SO, NICOLE, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
SO I THINK SHE'S GOT A GREAT
BUTT, BUT I DON'T SEE PINUP.
I JUST DON'T FEEL IT
IN THE BODY FOR ME, NOT WORKING.
I SAW A LOT OF SUBTLE
VARIATIONS IN HER.
SHE CAUGHT HERSELF, CAME BACK,
HUNG IN THERE.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS KYLE.
ALL RIGHT, KYLE, SO YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH ME,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT'S A LITTLE DEER
IN THE HEADLIGHTS,
BUT IT WORKS.
IT TOOK A WHILE
TO GET HERE, KYLE,
BUT YOUR IDEA OF MODELING IS...
YOU KNOW?
AND SO YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT
YOU CAN BE BEAUTIFUL AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TRY.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU TO PULL YOUR HAIR BACK TO
RELY ON OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE SEXY AND CONFIDENT
AND BEAUTIFUL.
BUT PEOPLE ON THE STREET
WHERE YOU'RE FROM
AT THE DAIRY QUEEN,
THEY'LL BE LIKE,
"SHE LOOKS CRAZY."
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
IT'S LIKE, WOW, IT'S DIFFERENT,
IT'S EDGY.
I KNOW WHAT SHE NEEDS, GUYS.
SHE NEEDS
SOME SISSIFICATION.
WHAT IS THAT?
SOME SISSIES TO BEAUTIFY HER.
SOME SISSIES THAT TURN HER OUT.
TO TURN HER OUT!
KYLE, SO YOU ALSO HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT AS A PINUP GIRL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
BODY LANGUAGE IS GREAT.
THE EXPRESSION'S
A BIT VACANT, ISN'T IT?
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT FIGURE.
YOU'VE GOT A MODEL'S FIGURE.
BEAUTIFUL.
BUT YOU'VE GOTTA BELIEVE
IN YOURSELF.
I THINK YOU COULD PUSH
YOURSELF SO MUCH FARTHER.
STOP WORRYING
ABOUT THE COMPETITION
AND JUST TRUST YOUR OWN TALENT.
ALL RIGHT,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, KIM,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU'VE BOUGHT A TICKET.
YOU'VE GOTTEN ON
THE GENDER-BENDER BUS AND NOW
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET OFF.
PUSH THE BELL, GIRL.
PICK A STOP.
I THINK I'VE BEEN SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME REALLY TRYING TO
LIKE BRING OUT
MY FEMININE SIDE.
SO WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN DOING
IN YOUR SISSIFICATION CLASS?
DATING BOYS, WHATEVER.
MAYBE BEING AROUND GIRLS
LIKE ALL DAY, EVERY DAY...
AND WHO'S THE PRISSIEST ONE
IN THE HOUSE THAT YOU KEEP
LIKE EMULATING?
UM, I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M EMULATING.
I MEAN, KYLE'S REALLY,
YOU KNOW, GIRLIE.
YOU'RE LISTENING AND YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO BE YOURSELF.
ALL RIGHT, KIM,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT WHERE
YOU HAD TO BE
A VERY FEMININE PINUP GIRL.
OH, THIS SHOULD BE GOOD.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOUR FILM SHOCKED THE HELL
OUT OF ME.
THIS IS SO LIKE
BEYOND FEMININE.
IT WAS AMAZING.
IF YOU'D HAVE SHOWN ME THAT,
I WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN
THAT WAS KIM.
SHE HAS THE CATCHER'S MITT.
LOOK AT THOSE PAWS.
THAT IS A PINUP GIRL.
AND IT'S THAT COME-HITHER
LOOK. IT'S LOVELY.
WHEN I KEPT SAYING THAT
I WANT YOU TO DO THE FEMININE
THING, LIKE MAKE SOME CHIFFON
GO WHOOSH AND SOME TAFFETA
GO SCRUNCH, SCRUNCH, SCRUNCH,
SCRUNCH, NOW I'M SEEING THAT
YOU DID HAVE THE POTENTIAL
THAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN SEEING
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING.
ALL RIGHTY.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THINGS ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THIS WEEK BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO JUDGE TWO PHOTOS.
IT'S GETTING REALLY HARD NOW.
KIM.
KIM-- I THINK SHE'S TAKING
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING TO HER
INTO CONSIDERATION, AND SHE'S
BEEN QUITE FEMININE, QUITE SOFT.
I WOULD NEVER HAVE BELIEVED
THIS IS THE SAME PERSON.
I THINK THIS IS
A TURNING POINT FOR TIM.
I CALLED HER TIM.
YOU SURE DID. I SAW THAT.
KIM BY DAY, TIM BY NIGHT.
I ACTUALLY THINK SHE'S HOT,
HOT, HOT, HOT, HOT, WHICH MEANS
I'M GETTING IN TOUCH WITH
MY ANDROGYNOUS FEMININE SIDE
MAYBE. I'M NOT REALLY SURE.
KYLE.
JUST UP AND DOWN WITH KYLE.
I LOVE THAT SHE LOOKS
A LITTLE BIT SAVAGE-LIKE,
THAT SHE CAN BREAK OUT
OF THAT WHOLE
SUBURBAN HOUSEWIFE,
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT
KYLE'S PINUP PICTURE,
IT'S NOTHING THERE.
THE PINUP PHOTOGRAPH--
THE BODY, AGAIN, IS GORGEOUS.
BUT WHEN WE TRY AND EXPLAIN
ABOUT A LOOK AND-- IT'S LIKE
IT JUST GOES COMPLETELY
OVER HER HEAD.
JUST THE LOOK ON HER FACE.
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT KYLE,
I'M THINKING, "WOW,
SHE'S THE CUTE ONE.
SHE'S THE HOT ONE."
THAT'S THE GIRL
IN HIGH SCHOOL THAT YOU SEE
THAT YOU THINK,
"WOW, SHE'S GORGEOUS."
I DIDN'T FEEL THE CONNECTION
WITH HER 100%,
BUT THIS PICTURE,
THE RAW PICTURE IS JUST
BEAUTIFUL. IT'S AMAZING.
NIK.
NIK IS REALLY GROWING ON ME.
I FIND HER EXOTIC
AND MESMERIZING, AND THAT IS
A MESMERIZING PHOTOGRAPH.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A CREATURE FROM
I DON'T KNOW WHERE.
LIKE SOME WILD SAVAGE--
YEAH, SOME WILD SAVAGE BEAUTY.
THE PROBLEM WITH NIK IS
HER SORT OF LACK
OF SELF-CONFIDENCE.
WHAT I WANT TO SEE NOW FROM HER
IS JUST TO TURN UP THE VOLUME
AND BECOME A PRESENCE IN FRONT
OF US.
THIS GIRL-- THIS FACE IS IN
THE RUNNING, BUT THE WORK THAT
SHE DID AND THEN THE WAY
SHE LOOKS WHEN I WOULD SEE HER
LIKE ON A CASTING
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
WHEN I WAS DOING
THE PHOTO SHOOT WITH NIK,
SHE WAS SO NERVOUS.
SO IT MAKES ME THINK,
WILL SHE BE INTIMIDATED IF SHE
SHOOTS WITH STEVEN MEISEL?
JAYLA.
I THINK JAYLA HAS A SPECIAL
QUALITY ABOUT HER, BUT I
BELIEVE SHE'S GOT ONE THING THAT
I DIDN'T FEEL FROM
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS-- DRIVE.
AND SHE'S MAKING CHANGES
AND SHE'S TAKING RISKS.
THE HANDS COULD BE
A LITTLE LESS LIKE A GECKO
STUCK ON THE SIDE OF A BUILDING.
I LOVE THAT SHE'S EXPOSING
HER EARS, WHICH IS THE THING
SHE'S ALWAYS TRIED TO HIDE.
I LIKE YOUR LOOK, TOO,
TODAY.
HER PINUP PHOTO IS VERY SEXY
AND KINDA TART, AND HER BOOTY IS
JUST KIND OF BOOP.
NICOLE.
I THINK SHE HAS STRONG
POTENTIAL.
SHE HAS THE LOOK OF A MODEL.
SHE HAS IT ALL GOING ON.
IN PERSON,
SHE'S JUST GOT THAT SOMETHING.
IT'S LIKE A SORT OF MOODY
TEENAGE ADOLESCENT THING
GOING ON.
I AGREE THAT THERE IS
A PERSONALITY PROBLEM.
BUT LET'S HOPE SHE WORKS
ON THAT.
I LOVE THE BLACK-AND-WHITE SHOT.
I MEAN,
THOSE EYES JUST GO THROUGH ME.
YES, THE EYES SORT OF
DO GO THROUGH ME
LIKE A BAG OF PRUNES. UM...
BRE.
HER PHOTOGRAPHS HAVE NEVER
QUITE WORKED FOR ME.
I THINK BRE DOESN'T GIVE
ENOUGH OPTIONS,
AND I THINK IT'S MORE
ON THE COMMERCIAL PRINT SIDE
THAN "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I THINK WHAT BRE REALLY HAS
IS A LOT OF SPUNK.
SHE MANAGES TO
SORT OF WIN YOU OVER,
AND I THINK THAT'S
SO IMPORTANT AT CASTING.
BRE STANDS IN FRONT OF ME,
(imitating Bre) AND SHE'S GOT
THAT SCRATCHY VOICE.
YOU KNOW, SHE TALKS LIKE THAT,
AND SHE'S JUST HAPPY TO BE HERE.
SHE REALLY TRIED, "AND, TYRA,
I REALLY WANT TO DO THIS."
(normal voice) IT'S JUST LIKE,
IT TOUCHES MY HEART.
LISA.
I COULD GO EITHER WAY
WITH HER.
LISA IS LIKE
THIS SORT OF ANOMALY.
I MEAN, SHE HAS THAT
ROCK-AND-ROLL THING WHICH IS
IS KINDA COOL, KINDA WORKS.
SHE LOOKS A LITTLE OLD.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT SHE'S
FROWNING IN THAT PICTURE.
IT'S BRILLIANT.
THIS RAW BLACK-AND-WHITE
PICTURE OF LISA ROCKS,
AND IT'S HARD TO DO
THE FURROWED BROW
AND BE PRETTY.
BUT SHE'S MANAGED TO SCRUNCH
HER BROW AND LEAVE THAT
LIP RELAXED.
THAT'S HARD.
THAT'S LIKE MUSCLE.
CAN YOU DO IT?
CHILD, WITH THESE LIPS?
♪♪♪
SEVEN BEAUTIFUL AND VERY
SEXY GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
AND USUALLY I WOULD SAY
THAT I HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
BUT THIS WEEK YOU GUYS DID
TWO PHOTO SHOOTS,
SO SEVEN GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HAND,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
KIM.
YOU KNOW YOU ROCKED THIS WEEK.
AND YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
LISA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I
WILL CALL...
NIK.
YOUR CHALLENGE IS, HOW CAN YOU
BE SEXY AND SUPPLE
AND WORK THE BODY THAT YOU HAVE?
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M
GOING TO CALL...
JAYLA, COME ON.
I'M COMING.
MISS PINKIE, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
OKAY, NICOLE.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT BEAUTY'S NOT JUST
ON THE OUTSIDE, IS IT?
NO, IT'S NOT.
WE WANT TO SEE HUMBLE
AND SWEET AND--
I DIDN'T REALLY REALIZE THAT
I WAS COMING ACROSS LIKE THAT.
BUT NOW YOU KNOW.
I KNOW.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL BRE AND KYLE PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE SET OF PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS, AND I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND GO HOME.
YOU TWO ARE STANDING BEFORE ME
FOR VERY DIFFERENT REASONS.
ONE OF YOU WE FEEL LIKE
WANTS THIS SO BADLY,
HAS STUDIED FASHION PROBABLY
MORE THAN A LOT OF THESE GIRLS,
BUT THE JUDGES BEHIND ME SEE
A SWEET, PRETTY GIRL
THAT MAY DO WELL DOING
COMMERCIAL PRINT MODELING,
BUT THEY'RE NOT SURE IF YOU CAN
SELL A CHANEL COUTURE GOWN.
AND THEN THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU,
AND WE SEE SOMEONE WITH ALL
THE POTENTIAL IN THE WORLD,
BEST BODY HERE,
TALLEST GIRL HERE,
THE FACE THAT CAN BE COMMERCIAL
FACE THAT CAN BE EDGY, BUT WE
SEE A GIRL THAT JUST MIGHT BE
STUCK IN HER HOMETOWN.
WE SEE SOMEONE THAT'S STUCK
BEING PRETTY, AND WE'RE NOT SURE
IF YOU CAN BE A PALETTE THAT CAN
BE PAINTED ON
AND THAT CAN BE TRANSFORMED,
SO ONE GIRL WITH ALL THE WANTS
AND "I HAVE TO BE THIS"
AND "I WANNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
AND ANOTHER GIRL THE JUDGES
THINK, STRONG LOOKS--
NOT ENOUGH.
AND THIS ONE PICTURE
WE SAW SOME POTENTIAL.
CONGRATULATIONS, BRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(cries)
THANKS, KYLE.
THANK YOU.
(sobbing)
I REALLY THOUGHT
THAT I WAS GONNA STAY.
I KNOW I HAVE ALL
THE POTENTIAL IN THE WORLD,
AND I JUST-- I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO USE IT.
BUT I DEFINITELY THOUGHT I WAS
GONNA GO FARTHER THAN THIS.
IT HURTS MY FEELINGS A LOT
THAT THEY DIDN'T SEE
THAT I WAS IMPROVING, 'CAUSE
I REALLY DID FEEL LIKE I WAS.
SO IT HURTS.
IT'S HARD TO SEE IT ALL GO.
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN LIVING HERE
FOR SO LONG, AND I WAS LIKE,
"THIS IS LIFE" AND I DON'T KNOW,
I'M LIKE, "WHAT AM I GONNA DO
WHEN I GO HOME NOW?"
IT'S JUST-- IT'S WEIRD.
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
INSPIRATION VISITS THE GIRLS
IN THE FORM
OF AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
EVA THE DIVA.
OH, MY GOD. SHE'S SO CUTE.
YOU JUST WANT TO KISS HER.
AND HOW CRAZY
WILL THINGS GET
WHEN LISA MEETS THE WILD BOYS?
♪♪♪
OW!